bonjour les bons coups merci de répondre
à nos questions on attaque la plus
sanglante au burkina depuis près de six
ans l'identité des assaillants n'est pas
été revendiqué qui en est l'auteur sur
le bout des groupes terroristes
djihadistes au fait pour le moment comme
vous le soulignez dakar n'a pas encore
été revendiqué mais comme nous le
savions depuis 2015 les regards se
croisent effectivement vers les
mouvements qui entretiennent
l'insécurité dans cette zone du détroit
fortier sa voile au mali le burkina et
le niger
donc nous avons ici la mouvance al qaïda
l'état islamique en l'occurrence mais
aussi le mouvement de fait qui
foisonnent au nord du mali depuis
quelques temps avec des mouvements sont
pas les attaques
également jeudi au nord est du mali donc
pays frontalier du burkina vous venez de
parler de pays transfrontaliers
depuis qu'ils font partie du g5 celle
avec également le niger le tchad de la
mauritanie
ces deux attaques est ce qu'elles sont
la conséquence de l'annoncé cette
semaine de paris de suspendre ses
activités militaires conjointes avec
bamako
mais ce qu'il convient de souligner que
les djihadistes stricte examinait au
microscope sociopolitique
les débats qui le traversent lorsqu'il
ya une faille donc il a saisi la
saisissent et créé des mouvements 26 et
cela nous amène à conserver une chose
c'est que la sécurité dans cette zone
aucun état local à dire aucune relation
entre l'eau manilow niger où le burkina
faso ne peut assumer à plein temps des
missions régaliennes en matière de
défense et de sécurité
il faut s'approche il faut s'accrocher
sur des partenariats solides des
partenaires solides qui permettent des
échanges d'informations si tel avait été
le cas
vous avez vu aussitôt que la france a
pris sa décision la carre immédiatement
est intervenu parce qu'on sait que quand
elles sont faites et la vigilance et est
retombé parce que si la france est
omniprésente
c'est aussi par lourd d'enseignements
technologie qui permet de repérer les
mouvements fait les différents groupes
en nation et une fois que ces fonctions
de p
les forces locales peut être actionné et
comme ce n'est pas toujours le cas parce
que cette fois-ci locales ne sont pas
opérationnels en plein temps c'est
l'opération back and qui fait toujours
d'écouler ses appareils pour contenir la
menace
et lorsqu'on observe que le partenaire
primordial à savoir la france hésite il
ya de fortes chances qu'on assiste dans
les prochains jours à des attaques
même si la force marque en continuant de
2 de son côté 5000 sont sommes
exactement ce sont leurs appels en les
opérations conjointes entre paris et
bamako qui sont suspendus mais pour
revenir sur ces deux attaques donc cette
du burkina celle du mali est ce qu'elles
peuvent exercer une forme de pression
sur le nouveau pouvoir malien notamment
donc avec leur au delà de la france est
et quel rôle également de ouagadougou
vis-à-vis de bamako et vice versa je
pense que lolo de ouagadougou
aujourd'hui il est assez clair
mais vous savez dans cette région il ya
toujours une paie assez précaire
lorsque le président
blaise compaoré était aux affaires au
burkina faso il avait entretenu et ctp
en allant directement négocié avec le
jihadiste ses fils au chaos malice et
philo car au niger ce fut le cas dans
son pot pays le burkina faso et lorsque
son successeur matin à bourg et était
arrivé au pouvoir il a dénoncé cette
situation
mais depuis quelques jours il se rend
compte qu'il est doux romu douce à
l'annoncé du 4 février dernier il a
décidé de tendre la main aux jihadistes
or entre temps il est apparu un acteur
totalement incontournable à savoir
l'état islamique qui ne veut pas
discuter avec cette détermination mais
aussi il ya le partenaire principal la
france qui est opposé à cette démarche
mais je pense que lorsqu'on regarde ce
qui se passe au mali c'est une situation
en quelque sorte insoutenable c'est à
dire on ne peut pas comprendre que dans
un pays où des forces étrangères sont
déployées c'est à dire pour essayer de
contenir la menace qui tend vers bamako
la seule chose qui puisse intéresser les
militaires ce n'est que au fait discuter
des positions de pouvoir au sein de
laquelle dans la capitale je pense que
la décision de la france est à dire elle
est totalement
elle est totalement illégitime et elle
est défendable et on attend autre chose
des militaires maliens que la discussion
des postures politiques à part ma peau
on parle beaucoup de la france
mais il ya aussi washington fin mai qui
a suspendu ses aides aux forces de
sécurité aux forces de défense malienne
fin mai après le coup de force du
colonel assimile aux états qui
d'ailleurs doit être investi demain un
président de la transition malienne sans
paris ni washington aux côtés des
troupes maliennes
est ce que ça peut dégénérer à quoi
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
concrètement dans la région ces
prochains jours ces prochaines semaines
sans que paris et washington comme vous
nous dit
situation est totalement intenable aucun
état dans cette sous-région assumer à
plein temps l'émission de gagner en
matière de sécurité mais alors aucun
aucun c'est-à-dire lee convient
également de souligner je pense qu'en
matière de sécurité faut être réaliste
c'est à dire la sécurité ce n'est pas le
domaine fait ces noms de domaine par
excellence du réalisme
il faut il faut sortir des déclarations
à l'emporté pièce or on observe
aujourd'hui que ce soit au burkina au
mali ou au niger et on observait une
remontée du patriotisme c'est à dire qui
est exacerbée et qui aboutit
nationaliser avec cinq ans avec pour
conséquence la fermeture à
l'universalisme
c'est à dire comment fait-on
concrètement mais contenir une menace
globale si on se permet déjà aux
partenaires c'est à dire si on tient un
discours qui ne va pas je dirais dans le
sens et des intérêts des partenaires ont
commencé sans manquer de respect qui est
attristant et je pense que il faut que
ces pays se serait-il et que qu'ils
sachent tout fait le terrorisme battu
carey des partenaires fiables
est-ce que avec la décision de paris est
ce que c'est une prise de risque
également de s'exposer à des attentats
sur le sol européen
non le lieu n'a jamais été clairement
fait ça dit parce qu'on a toujours dit
que la france
en intervenant sahel sadi c'est une
façon en quelque sorte de véhicules et
jets dirait la frontière c'est à dire
pour contenir la menace à distance c'est
à dire il n'y a jamais eu d'attentât en
terre française d'aviron montrant que
c'est qu'il avait perpétré venez
directement d'israël moi je pense que la
france a une très grande responsabilité
dans la région une responsabilité qui
est d'ordre historique qui est d'ordre
moral
parce que comme je le soulignais ces
états sont des états faibles du point de
vue militaire est la préoccupation de
l'occident aujourd'hui c'est de ne pas
avoir cette zone et s'ériger au fait un
sit in et à venir à vis ce fut le délire
à un moment donné mais je pense que
c'est des sacs et des questions
aujourd'hui
merci les hong kong ou d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue spécialiste des relations
internationales et donc des relations
entre nations africaines également